بعد القصه اللي راح اشاركها معكم الان
حتتاكدوا ان العمر مجرد رقم وانه ما في
شيء يمنع الانسان من تحقيق اهدافه الدكتور
عبد القويس دبلوماسي ومصرفي سعودي متقاعد
في الثمانيه من عمره قرر يبدا رحله اقل ما
يقال عنها ان مغامره بكل ما للكلمه من
معنى مغامره الدكتور عبد الله تسلق جبال
الهملايا بهدف الوصول الى قمه بتدفعها
اكثر من 8000
و800 متر ودكتور عبد الله بيوثق رحلته
بشكل لطيف على تويتر فبيكتب تغريدات وبيحط
صور وفيديوهات وفي وحده من التغريدات حتى
كمان عن قيامه بهذه الرحله ردا على سؤال
بولنديه حسناء حسب ما وصفها مدير التمويل
مشاريع احد بنوقهم سالته ما دفعك لذلك في
هذا العمر فانه هو تحديدا عمره 84 فقال
انه تحدي النفس ديننا يحث على محاربه
النفس التي تدفع للاستكانه وللعيش الرقيق
مقاطع فيديو كثيره وثقت رحلات او لحظات من
رحله دكتور عبد الله وهو بيحاول تسلق جبل
الهملايا بهمه وعزم للوصول للقمه خلينا
نشوف بعضها سوا
استمتع
بالله
[موسيقى]
لا سمح الله
هذا ينقض كل ينقط عشره اشكالك
خمس ساعات باسكان تقريبا
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]